hallo
Ist schon am start
Und hier ist schon da
Ammo box camper hier bevor die leute anfangen max hat es dringend erinnert ich habe hier genug dabei
Er könnte mich trotzdem erinnern weil irgendwo müssen die channel points dahin
Erinnert mich ruhig habe ich eigentlich
alles
Ausgemacht
Ja kein blubber mehr kein color correction müsste eigentlich alles passen
ja setke
aber besser so
Wegen war ich gestern auch nicht
Schon mal die vm an
wollen major pain
Vor allem wer nervt nicht
Deswegen war ich gestern auch nicht
Dabei hätte ich gestern wieder harten
kreise klein machen müssen
Aber heute machen wir erst mal tag 2 und 3
auf code weil wir sind hinten dran wir sind mittlerweile schon bei tag 9 und erst tag 1 gemacht
Ja oder gut ich genug urlaub für kreise klein habe ich auch das stimmt wohl
Ja wir sind wir sind wir sind schon bei tag 9
Und wir machen heute tag 2 und 3 oder mal gucken mal gucken wie weit wir machen hängt natürlich auch ein bisschen davon ab
Ja also Hello
Und
Wie schwer das ganze ist
und
Ob ich mich so in der geistigen verfassung befinde das zu machen soll man einfach package updates weil arch bei der weh ach so und ich hab ein
Ein
r ***
Das war Tag 1, wenn ich richtig in Erinnerung habe.
Ich glaube, das hat auch gestimmt.
Lass mal kurz schauen.
Tag 1 hatten wir gelöst.
Kalender.
Ja.
Okay, Tag 1 haben wir gelöst.
Dann kommt heute Tag 2.
So, ich habe ein Repo angelegt.
Da pushen wir das gleich mal rein.
Advent Champ 2023.
Moment.
Ich muss das Repo umbenennen.
Ich bin ja schon...
Guck mal.
Ich habe mein Repo falsch genannt.
Ich habe mein Repo Advent of Code genannt.
Das ist aber eigentlich falsch.
Das müsste Advent Champ 2023 heißen.
Egal.
Komm, da weiß jemand...
Warte mal, ich muss Headset entknoten.
Weil so verknotet...
Egal, geht schon.
So verknotet ist es gar nicht.
Da wissen die Leute wenigstens was mit anzufangen, okay?
Wahrscheinlich sogar besser, wenn das so heißt.
Ich push mal den Kram vom letzten Mal.
Und dann machen wir heute Tag 2 und Tag 3.
Vielleicht, wie gesagt, ich weiß noch nicht genau, wie weit ich da komme.
Vielleicht machen wir auch nur Tag 2.
Und ich mache es in C-Sharp und in Bash oder irgendwie sowas.
Was ganz abgedreht ist.
Mal gucken, wie kompliziert das ist.
Ich habe schon ein bisschen gespickt.
Zumindest Teil 1 sieht relativ gut aus.
Easy aus.
Kobol.
Warum nicht gleich?
Wie heißt diese komische SAP-Programmiersprache?
A...
Irgendwas mit A am Anfang.
ABAP.
ABAP, genau.
Ja, ja.
Warum nicht gleich in ABAP, man?
Ich push den ganzen Kram.
Git, Remote.
Ach, guck mal, haben wir es noch.
Wobblors.
Advent of Code.
Git-Status.
Wir müssen mal kurz gucken.
Vielleicht sollten wir das umbenennen.
Weil bei mir heißt das 2023.
Das ist aber dumm.
Weil das...
Aber das hier machen wir mal zu.
Weil eigentlich...
Also ich sollte alles aus dem Repo da reinpushen.
Das heißt, ich würde eigentlich vorschlagen, wir nennen das mal um.
In...
Aber hier mal zu.
Wir benennen das mal um.
In...
Advent of Code.
Einfach nicht.
Advent-Champ 2023.
Und dann machen wir hier einen Ordner für 2023.
Und da schieben wir das alles rein.
2023.
Wo ist mein Git-Ignore-File?
Irgendwo muss doch mein Git-Ignore-File noch sein.
Habe ich kein Git-Ignore-File?
Oder habe ich das hier drin?
Ich habe...
Ja, das ist PP-Gar, wenn ich kein Git-Ignore-File habe.
Dann adde ich jetzt ja da auch alle Binaries.
Moment.
Hier, Git-Ignore.
Was?
Git-Ignore.
FFM-Pack gibt es nicht.
Aber dieser ganze Müll, der kommt da nicht mit.
Gut.
Moment.
Habe ich da...
Habe ich da schon Git-Repo?
Okay, ich hatte da schon Git-Repo angelegt anscheinend.
Ja gut, ist ja nicht schlimm.
Ist ja nicht schlimm.
Aber ich habe zu viel geaddet.
Ich...
Das ist Blödsinn, was ich hier gemacht habe.
Wir entfernen...
Wir entfernen den Git...
Das Git-Verzeichnis nochmal.
Und sagen Git-Init.
Git-Add.
Git-Ignore.
Ach ja, hier hatte ich doch schon ein Git-Ignore drin.
Ja, ich bin ein bisschen verwirrt.
So.
2023.
Git-Status.
Git-Add.
Ah, genau.
Der fügt jetzt nämlich...
Wirklich nur die Projekte und die Input-Dateien ein.
Dann ist das ganz gut.
Git-Commit-A-N-Day-One.
Shadows.
Git-Push-Origin.
Master.
Ach so, Remote-Add.
Oh, mein Master-Branch heißt noch Master.
Gleich ganz Twitter-triggert.
So.
Okay, gut.
Passt.
Alles klar, hier ist der Krempel.
Gut, da haben wir die Vorbereitung abgeschlossen.
Ich habe heute auf Reddit ein Post empfohlen bekommen,
weil wenn man die Reddit-App hat, gibt es ja immer so Empfehlungen.
Und irgendwo hat einer einen News-Artikel gepostet.
Ich habe mir den aber noch nicht angeguckt.
Vielleicht können wir uns den nachher zusammen...
angucken.
Ich habe noch nicht reingeguckt.
Irgendwie, dass Studien belegen, Home-Office ist schlecht und wie die Unternehmen die Leute
wieder ins Büro kriegen und sowas.
Aber ich habe in den Reddit-Kommentaren schon gelesen, dass dieser Artikel wohl etwas einseitig
geschrieben ist.
Ja.
Ja, das Geile ist halt, die Leute denken jetzt auch noch, sie haben die Welt gerettet danach.
So nach dem Motto, ey, jetzt ist alles gut.
Jetzt gibt es kein Rassismus mehr.
Ja.
Kein Rassismus, keine Diskriminierung mehr, weil der Branche jetzt Main heißt.
Das ist alles weg.
Ja.
Aber es hindert keinen daran, einfach rauszugehen.
Man muss nicht auf die Arbeit gehen, um rauszugehen.
Das ist halt das Ding.
Ist bei mir auch so.
Eines der Hauptgründe, warum ich da hin bin, wo ich jetzt bin, ist, weil die natürlich
lieber Geld und dass die Sachen an sich auch gut passen und so, weil die eine gute Home-Office-Regelung
haben.
Aber nochmal, ich verstehe diese Diskussion darum ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Es gibt ja wirklich Bereiche, wo man echt die Augen aufmachen muss und gucken, ey, da
gibt es wirklich noch, wie soll man sagen, offenkundig große Missstände, dass es irgendjemand
vor Mobbing oder Gedisse schützt, dass der Branche von Git, der standardmäßig angelegt
wird in irgendeinem Repo, jetzt nicht mehr Master, sondern Main heißt.
Seriously.
Davon geht es keinem auf der Welt besser.
Außer, dass du dich sinnlos umgewöhnen musst.
Einfach.
Ja, bei mir ist es ähnlich.
Also, wir haben es mittlerweile so gemacht, dass wir ungefähr einmal die Woche da sind.
Jeder, jeder von uns ungefähr einmal die Woche da.
Wir versuchen das meistens so an dem Tag, wo Gruppenrunde ist, ein bisschen zu konzentrieren,
dass man sich mal über den Weg läuft.
Aber ansonsten funktioniert das wunderbar.
Man muss echt nicht, also man kann, man kann gar nichts sagen.
Wir sind auch irgendwie nicht unangenehm.
Wir sind uninformierter, dadurch, dass wir im Homeoffice sind, sogar besser, weil wenn
in Teams einer grün ist, kannst du ihn in der Regel auch anrufen.
Nicht so, wie wenn die Leute irgendwie im Büro sind.
Du denkst, oh ja, ich geh mal kurz vorbei gucken, guckst bei dem rein, ist er gerade
am Telefonieren, setzt sich 10 Minuten hin, wartet, bis der fertig ist, dann schwätzt
du noch ein bisschen.
Total sinnlos.
Homeoffice ist viel besser.
Und wisst ihr, wisst ihr, wer eh die besten Homeoffice-Leute sind?
Das sind Leute, das habe ich ja schon tausendmal gesagt, auch ganz am Anfang, als die alle,
Moment, ich muss noch ein bisschen andere Musik machen.
Das ist ja immer der gleiche, gleiche Loop.
Hier, mal ein bisschen Wupp, Wupp, Wupp.
Wupp, Wupp, Wupp, Wupp, Wupp, Wupp, Wupp.
Jawoll.
Ja, das Beste, das Beste sind tatsächlich Leute mit Online-Game-Erfahrung und am besten
Leute mit Multiplayer-Online-Game-Erfahrung.
Sei es jetzt irgendwelche World of Warcraft Raider, Dark PvP-Leute oder einfach nur Clan
CS-Spieler oder sowas.
Leute, die wissen, wie man gescheit online mit anderen spricht und gerade Leute, die
ein bisschen, ich nenne es mal absichtlich so einfach, Competitive-Gaming-Erfahrung
haben, die sind richtig gut, was Homeoffice angeht.
Die wissen, dass man in Teams nicht schreiben muss, sehr geehrter Herr Max, mit Erschrecken
habe ich zur Kenntnis genommen, dass der Service seit 23.53 Uhr die Nicht-Verfügbarkeits-Seite
anzeigt.
Bitte dringend prüfen und darüber den E-Mail-Verteiler informieren.
Mit freundlichen Grüßen, Ihr Anwendungsverantwortlicher.
Ja.
Wenn er schon so anfängt, da weißt du Bescheid.
Aber gerade, gerade am.
Ohne Scheiß.
Gerade am Anfang.
Ja.
Hast du sofort gemerkt, wer Online-Game-Erfahrung hat.
Du hast dann Leute in Teams, die haben geschrieben, moin, kannst du mal hier gucken.
So, fertig.
Kannst du mal hier gucken und haben gleich den Link gepostet.
Und da wusstest du Bescheid.
Und im Zweifelsfall hast du dann mal kurz auf Call gedrückt bei denen.
Hast dann hier, ich hab geguckt, probier mal aus, probier mal aus, ob es geht.
Zeig mal, wie das eigentlich aussieht.
Dann hat er schnell sein Screen geshared, gezeigt, aha, geht, passt wieder, alles gut.
Also, du hast sofort gemerkt, oder auch, wenn man irgendwelche Besprechungen hatte,
so die in der Anfangszeit, irgendwelche Team-Meetings, wo dann,
ach, kurz was dringen, auch am Anfang, irgendwelche Team-Meetings,
wo dann die ganzen Leute, die ganzen Manager-Leute irgendwie sich überflüssig vorgekommen sind.
Und anstatt, dass man einfach über irgendwas reden konnte,
wurde dann irgendwie so komische Dinge eingeführt, wie,
ja,
nachdem es jetzt ja für uns alle so schwierig ist und wir jetzt alle nur zu Hause sitzen,
machen wir jetzt, keine Ahnung,
virtuell stoßen wir jetzt alle mal im Teams zusammen an,
macht doch mal alle eure Kamera an und winkt euch zu.
Und wir haben alle da gesessen und gesagt, Alter, geh weg, Mensch.
Lass uns halt einfach unseren Kram machen, geh mir nicht auf den Sack.
Ihr kennt das, ihr kennt das vielleicht auch, ja.
Und der Witz war, die Leute so mit Online-Gamer,
mit Online-Erfahrung, schon in Teams nebenbei geschrieben, so,
lull, jetzt kommt das wieder, so untereinander, wisst ihr.
Ja, sowas in der Richtung haben sie bei uns auch probiert, beim letzten Arbeitgeber, keine Ahnung.
Ich bin aber eh nie auf die Weihnachtsfeier gegangen, also auch nicht auf die digitale.
Ja.
Und was du am Anfang von Homeoffice halt auch extrem gemerkt hast,
du hast ein paar Leute mit Online-Erfahrung,
die wussten, wie man redet über Teams,
die wussten, wie man das Mikrofon sich nicht in den Popo schiebt,
bevor man irgendwie reinreden will,
die wussten, dass es scheiße ist, wenn permanent im Hintergrund der Staubsauger läuft,
die wussten einfach, wie man kurz, klar, knackig,
ohne die anderen Leute abzufacken, online kommuniziert.
Das waren auch die einzigen Leute, die wussten,
dass sowas wie Push-to-Talk sinnvoll ist.
Ich meine, in Teams kannst du ja nicht so direkt pushen,
push-to-talk machen, aber du kannst quasi mute, mute-to-mute machen.
Also, du kannst in Teams, machst du das Gegenteil von push-to-talk.
Du mutest dich, wenn du nichts zu sagen hast.
Das kommt im Prinzip aufs Gleiche raus, musst deinen Kopf drücken.
Und das haben nur Leute mit Online-Game-Erfahrung gecheckt.
Bei den anderen, bei den anderen hast du dann im Hintergrund irgendwie die Kinder schreien,
den Staubsauger am Start, den Fernseher.
Ja, Leute mit dem Mikrofon und sowas.
Gigacringe, ja, das waren dann auch so Dinger.
Aber mittlerweile, mittlerweile,
dabei kriegen es die Leute hin.
Und was auch witzig war am Anfang,
als diese ganze Homeoffice-Geschichte angefangen hat,
diese Suche nach Software dafür.
Erinnert ihr euch noch dran,
als am Anfang Zoom aufgekommen ist?
Niemand kannte Zoom bis daher.
Und alle haben es an Zoom benutzt.
Und witzigerweise ging dann auch, Moment,
irgendwann ging dann die,
diese,
die Aktie von Zoom
voll durch die Decke
mit dem Unterschied,
es war damals noch gar nicht die Zoom-Aktie,
sondern irgendein anderes Unternehmen,
das Zoom hieß.
Da haben die Leute random eine Zoom-Aktie gekauft,
die mit Zoom gar nichts zu tun hatte.
Du bist einst, was, was?
Du bist einst von deiner Belohnung verfolgt.
Ja, das ist wirklich Dice-Off.
Das ist auch so ein Feature, das hat auch keiner gebraucht.
Aber auf der anderen Seite, ich gehe davon aus,
Twitch, die sind ja nicht blöd, ja.
Die haben das analysiert und haben festgestellt,
dass da so Viewer-Engagement bringt,
wenn man sowas sharen kann.
Also dann, dann engaged mal.
Cringe-Choke wieder hier.
Chat geht, Community geht.
Ja, ja, das ist gut.
Ich habe auch so ein paar Leute, wo ich weiß,
also sowohl auf der alten Arbeit als auch auf der aktuellen Arbeit,
wo ich auch weiß, dass sie online,
sagen wir mal so, Online-Gaming-Erfahrungen haben.
Mit denen schreibe ich nebenbei auch immer ein bisschen,
wenn irgendwas bescheuertes kommt.
Aus Rumänien.
Dort, wo ich jetzt arbeite, haben wir auch
ein Off-Site, frag mich nicht, wie das heißt,
ein Off-Site, frag mich nicht, wie das heißt, ein Off-Site, frag mich nicht, wie das heißt, ein Off-Site, frag mich nicht, wie das heißt,
frag mich nicht, wie das genau heißt,
Entwicklerstudio
aus,
es könnte auch Rumänien sein?
Ich bin mir da jetzt gar nicht sicher.
Aber irgendwo, irgendwo diese Ecke
ist das.
Falls später wieder Ragequit kommt.
Ach, das ist der Advent of Code Erfinder.
Hast du, hast du schon
das Video von ApoRed gesehen?
Moment, der hat wieder ein neues Video, nein,
glaube ich nicht.
Gibt's was Neues zum
Insi-Modus, oder wie?
Wo hat er die denn jetzt auf einmal her?
Ich dachte, Dubai ist das neue Meta.
Und außerdem,
Moment, Moment, war's nicht so,
war's nicht so, dass der jetzt voll den krassen
Trader, Trading-Hase
macht und da jetzt
voll abgeht?
Aber, wie sagt man
so schön, Selbsterkenntnis
ist der erste Weg zur Besserung. Ob das lange
hält, weiß man ja nicht.
3,6 Millionen
Steuerschulden.
Du musst erstmal krass viel verdienen, dass du überhaupt so viel
Steuerschulden machen kannst. Na gut.
Ne, interessiert, also
ich, ich, ich guck mir das nicht an.
Sollen sie alle machen.
Ja.
Sein Steuerberater hat ihm
gesagt, er muss teure
Was, okay,
das ist, okay, ich kenn das Video nicht,
aber solche Aussagen glaube ich eh
immer nur so zur Hälfte.
Also mein Steuerberater
hat mir noch nie gesagt, Max,
du musst unbedingt dir jetzt, ähm,
keine Ahnung,
ne Rolex kaufen oder so.
So einfach random. So übrigens,
Herr Max, wissen Sie, es wird mal langsam
Zeit, sich ne, sich ne Rolex zu kaufen.
So.
Warum?
Macht keinen Sinn.
Der Steuerberater sagt, er soll in die Gruppe, Gruppe kommen, ja.
Das sind die Besten.
Ich, ich, ich muss mir
kein Fiat kaufen, ich muss mir eigentlich als nächstes
ein Jeep kaufen, dann
nen...
Was ist da noch alles dabei?
Fiat,
Jeep, ich müsste mir quasi
die komplette Fiat Champ Autogruppe
kaufen, um zu checken, um zu testen,
ob der Fiat Champ auch immer funktioniert.
Wo wir gerade dabei sind, ich glaube, es gibt immer noch
keine, keine Issues, oder?
Ne, keine Issues.
Oh, da hat jemand was
geupdatet. 15. Oktober.
Nice. Hab ich gar nicht
gesehen, schon eine Weile her.
Immer noch keine Fehler, obviously.
So, also.
Ich zeige euch mal, wobei,
ich wollte gerade mal einen Standardspruch bringen.
Ich zeige euch mal, wo wir stehen geblieben sind.
Macht aber gar keinen Sinn, weil wir nirgendwo stehen geblieben sind.
Wir waren mit Tag 1 fertig.
Aber Tag 2 und 3.
Also.
Legen wir mal los.
Nein.
Sind sie nicht.
Ich hab, das nicht, das sind sie
definitiv nicht. Ich hab den, ich hab den
Namen der Stadt vergessen. Wenn ich ihn höre,
weiß ich es vielleicht wieder.
Es ist eine Stadt, die man nicht oft hört.
Hab ich, hab ich vorher noch nie gehört.
So.
Also, dann gehen wir mal hier.
Wir haben 2023.
Tag 1.
Tag 2, Aufgabe 1.
New Console.
Dann legen wir mal los, machen das auf und dann gucken wir uns
die Aufgabe an.
Wie gesagt, ich hab, ich hab schon mal kurz
gespickt.
Äh. Falsch.
Weiß doch nicht. Adventure Champ. So.
Kurz gespickt und das sah
gar nicht so. Ah.
02, 01 ist falsch.
Es ist 02.
Siehste? Schon mal wieder verkackt hier.
Nicht 02, 01. Es ist
MK Deer 02,
1. So.
Weil es gibt ja nur 2 Aufgaben am Tag.
New Console.
2000.
Ups.
Alter, ich bin grad viel zu
pepega, irgendwie überhaupt was zu bedienen.
Okay.
Ähm.
Ryder ist pfeiffertiger, als ich gedacht hab.
Ryder macht jetzt einfach alle Projekte auf. Nice.
Soll mir auch recht sein. Okay.
Zack. Zack.
Advent of Code.
2003 01.
Äh.
Alter, heute, heute kann ich echt, kann's echt
vergessen jetzt. Run.
What?
Hä? Moment.
Was zum? Alter, ich bin ja
MK Deer.
01.
New Console.
Gut. Open.
Okay. Run.
Jetzt aber. Meine Güte. Schwere
Geburt. So. Dann schauen wir uns noch mal an,
was die Aufgabe von heute ist, würde ich sagen.
Mal gucken. Mal gucken.
Also mein Plan ist, dass wir heute Tag
2 und 3 machen. Oh, shit.
So weit kommen wir heute nicht.
Ich muss mal schauen, wie lang
mein Brain heute durchhält. Ich bin immer noch
ein bisschen mitgenommen von gestern.
Deswegen.
Vielleicht nur Tag 2. Schauen wir mal.
Oder vielleicht auch gar nichts.
Mal gucken. Also. Hier sind wir stehen geblieben.
Advent of Code.
Wer das Ganze nicht kennt, ich werd's mal ganz
kurz erklären. Es gibt
jedes Jahr, gibt es so ein
Weihnachtskalender.
Quasi. Ich dachte übrigens ursprünglich, dass es von
GitHub kommt. Ist aber komplett falsch. Das kommt nicht
von GitHub. Das kommt von
Eric Wastl.
Von was punktet's eigentlich?
Eine richtig gute Domain, oder?
Der erstellt das jedes Jahr. Das ist auch
wo jemand den Vortrag vorhin gepostet
hat.
Und zwar sind das 24,
also wie so ein Adventskalender,
24 Tage. Jeden Tag
wird was Neues freigeschaltet.
Und jeden Tag gibt es 2 Aufgaben.
Also ihr seht, wir haben erst Tag 1 erledigt.
Also richtig cringe.
Wir sind quasi die Hälfte hinten dran.
Nee, C++. Heute nicht.
Heute probier ich, wenn ich noch Zeit habe,
die Aufgabe in Bash zu machen.
Mal gucken, ob wir's in Bash hinkriegen.
C++ hab ich letztes Mal nicht durchgehalten.
So, Tag 1.
Tag 1 haben wir
umgesetzt. Also nur, dass ihr
euch ungefähr so vorstellen
könnt, was auf einen zukommt.
Das war alles für Tag 1, Aufgabe 1.
Und das hier war alles für
Tag 1, Aufgabe 2.
Also die ganzen Sachen sind immer relativ
übersichtlich.
Also nur, zum Beispiel,
es gibt einen randomizeden Input.
Was war jetzt hier für Tag 1?
Es gibt einen randomizeden Input.
Und man sollte rausfinden,
was die erste und letzte Zahl,
wohlgemerkt Zahl. Nicht, dass nicht
wenn ihr 2 steht oder so. Die erste und letzte
Zahl ist, daraus eine
zweistellige Zahl machen und die dann am Ende
zusammenrechnen.
Sieht dann, sah dann so aus.
Und am Ende kam dann halt
irgendwie raus, keine Ahnung,
63.000 oder
59.000 oder irgendwie sowas.
Also es ist relativ übersichtlich. Mal gucken,
wie das Ganze heute aussieht.
Die Aufgaben schwanken übrigens auch
in Schwierigkeit. Also es ist nicht
gesagt, dass
Tag 1 leichter ist als Tag
3 oder so, zwangsläufig.
Aber Aufgabe
2 ist meistens schwerer als Aufgabe
1 an dem jeweiligen Tag.
Kein Regex.
Tatsächlich kein Regex.
Übrigens auf
die Idee bin ich gekommen, sondern der Chat.
Ich hab's auch am Anfang mit
Regex gemacht, aber ich hab
Teil 2 mit
Regex gelöst. Hier, guck.
Oder Regex,
wie die coolen Leute sagen.
Leute, seid ihr eher der
Regex-Aussprecher
oder der Regex?
Ich bin ja für Regex.
Gag-Ex. Ich bin auch für
Regex. Nicht Regex.
Regex erinnert mich so an WebEx.
Und WebEx ist ganz grausame
Videokonferenz des Gedöns.
Muss jemand von euch, manch
mal, WebEx benutzen?
Also mein Beileid schon mal,
ja? Von
Cisco. Das sag ich lustigerweise
Cisco. Aber es gibt auch Leute, die sagen
Ziz... Cisco.
WebEx ist
richtig, richtig...
Ist das E-Mode nicht normalerweise
anders? So irgendwie...
Na, egal. Anscheinend
nicht.
Ich hab das E-Mode schon gesehen, aber
unter anderem...
Unter anderem...
E-Mode-Begriff.
Ja,
es ist ja auch die Frage, ob es
Jason oder Josson heißt.
Also, wir wissen ja, dass sogar der
Jason-Erfinder der Meinung ist,
dass es nicht Jason, Jason
heißt, sondern Josson.
Genau, genau.
Josson.
So, also, dann lasst uns mal angucken,
wie lange wir rumschwätzen, weil
nachher, weiß ich nicht, ob ich streamen soll,
kann sich der Chat überlegen,
nachher muss ich Cryzalkind weitermachen.
Ich muss sowohl in Alp meine
Sorg weiter ausrüsten,
ähm, in Mid mein Skull weiter
ausrüsten, theoretisch noch ein Charmy-Level
und ein bisschen PvP machen.
So.
Was ist denn da stehen geblieben?
Also, Aufgabe Tag 2.
Wie immer, kann man den Anfang
erstmal vergessen. Der Anfang ist, der
Anfang ist immer Story.
Also, die Story dieses Jahr
ist, wir sind
von den Elfen beauftragt
worden, zu gucken,
warum es an 50 Stellen
auf der Welt nicht
richtige Schneeproduktion gibt.
Und dafür müssen wir
die ganzen Aufgaben lösen.
Aber die Story, wie bei MMOs,
interessiert uns nicht, deswegen
skippen wir die Story einfach.
Okay.
Also.
As you walk, the elf
shows you a small
bag and some cubes.
Okay, das ist immer noch Story.
Ah ne, wobei, wobei, okay.
Es gibt verschiedene Würfel mit den Farben
Rot, Grün und Blau.
Also, der Elf
spielt wohl irgendein Spiel mit uns, okay.
Ähm, jedes Mal,
wenn man das Spiel spielt,
versteckt er irgendeine geheime, äh,
versteckt er eine geheime Nummer
von Würfeln von jeder Farbe
in dem Sack.
Und das Ziel ist es,
oh, das liest sich schon eklig.
Wenn ich solche,
es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten bei solchen Aufgaben
immer. Erste Möglichkeit
ist, es wird ganz eklig,
weil du verstehen musst, was
eigentlich passiert und das dann irgendwie nachbauen, oder
das ist alles nur Ablenkung,
Distraction vom eigentlichen Problem
und hat damit gar nichts zu tun.
Okay.
Äh, and your goal is to figure out, äh,
information about the number of cubes.
Okay.
Also, to get info, äh,
to get information, once
a bag, nee, once
a bag has been loaded with cubes, the elf
will
reach into the bag, grab
a handful of random cubes,
show them to you and then put
them back in the bag, okay.
Und das macht er
mehrfach pro Spiel.
Okay,
ich spiele mit dem Elf mehrere Spiele
und, äh, wir
notieren uns quasi von jedem Spiel,
was der Elf
für
Würfel gezogen hat.
Jedes Spiel, okay, das war wirklich
alles komplett unsinnige, äh,
Zusatzinformationen, jetzt kommt eigentlich das
Interessante. Ja,
ähm,
okay, jedes Game in meinem
Input besteht aus einer ID,
sieht man ja auch hier, also
Game 1, das ist, das ist, das ist dann im Endeffekt
die ID,
und dann
followed by a semi-colon
separated list, quasi
von, nennen wir es mal von
einzelnen Spielzügen, könnte
man glaube ich so sagen. Also
sprich, im ersten Spiel
hat der Elf quasi drei blaue,
vier rote,
nee,
doch, drei
blaue, vier rote
Würfel gezogen, beim
nächsten Schritt ein roten,
zwei grüne, sechs blaue, und beim
dritten Schritt nur zwei grüne.
Okay, also das ist quasi unser Input,
beziehungsweise den eigentlichen
Input gibt's, gibt's dann hier,
ja, das ist ein bisschen mehr,
dass man hier nicht bruteforcen kann.
Also,
for example, okay, das, das
ist ein Beispielinput, denn damit fangen
wir mal an, da ist nicht so viel. Das ist
ein Beispielinput
von
Spielen, die ich mit
dem Elf gespielt habe.
Okay, also das ist jetzt ein Beispiel,
im ersten Spiel, also
in dem hier, wurde
dreimal gezogen, ja,
also, ne, erster
Step, zweiter Step,
dritter Step,
ey, ich muss bestimmt jetzt irgendwie
sowas ausrechnen, wie
viele Würfel noch übrig sind und so
Zeug, in,
in, okay, also
three sets of cubes are revealed from the back, ja,
das haben wir gesehen,
dann wurden sie wieder reingesteckt,
the first set is three blue,
drei blaue,
vier rote, second
is
ein roter, zwei grüne,
sechs
blaue, und der dritte
Step ist zwei grüne, okay,
das habe ich soweit gecheckt.
So, und jetzt will der Elf von
uns wissen,
which games
would have been possible
if the bag contained only
one of red cubes, thirteen green cubes,
fourteen blue cubes,
ey, ich kenne doch die Regeln von
dem Spiel überhaupt nicht, was weiß ich,
keine Ahnung, wo soll ich das wissen,
okay, das ist wahrscheinlich,
im Prinzip können wir alles
vergessen, wir können das hier alles vergessen,
das ganze Gelaber können wir vergessen,
ist vollkommen egal,
ist vollkommen egal, wie das Spiel funktioniert,
ehrlich gesagt,
ich vermute,
die wollen von uns,
dass man die Anzahl
aller
Würfel pro Runde zählt,
und dann guckt, ob die kleiner,
die, also,
wir zählen alle blaue Würfel,
also in dem Fall
neun,
und gucken, ob es kleiner vierzehn ist.
Wir zählen alle roten
Würfel, also
vier, fünf,
gucken, ob das kleiner als
zwölf ist, und so weiter.
Oh, Chat,
ihr sagt, ihr habt recht, stimmt,
die stecken, nach jeder Runde werden die Würfel
ja zurück in den Sack gesteckt, also
muss ich nicht alles zusammenzählen, sondern
nur gucken, in welchem
Step die
größte Anzahl an Würfeln
von einer bestimmten Farbe gezogen
wurde.
So, und alles, okay,
okay, das ist tatsächlich gar nicht
so kompliziert, glaube ich,
wir gehen das einfach der Reihe nach durch,
wir nehmen die erste Zeile,
dann splitten wir das auf, wir
holen uns die ID raus,
wir holen uns
die,
die ans, wobei, nö, noch nicht mal,
wir holen uns nicht mal die ID raus, wir holen,
wir brauchen die ID nicht, wir holen uns
die, das, da machen wir
wieder Regex-Magic, wir holen
uns quasi von,
von jedem,
jedes quasi,
ja, Würfelpaar kann man das nicht nennen,
also jedes, jedes Würfel,
jeder Würfelzug holen
wir uns raus, und gucken,
was ist die größte Anzahl an
Zügen von blauen Würfeln,
die größte Anzahl an Zügen von roten Würfeln, also,
bei Game 1 wäre das dann quasi,
das hier ist der erste Zug,
das hier der zweite, das, das der dritte,
so, und von jedem das höchste, hier werden
drei blaue gezogen, hier werden sechs blaue
gezogen, das heißt, sechs blaue Würfel wären das,
hier werden vier rote gezogen, hier nur
ein roter, also vier und
zwei, also quasi sechs, vier,
zwei, also vier rot,
sechs blau, zwei grün,
und jetzt muss ich gucken,
ist das kleiner,
quasi, ähm, ist
vier kleiner zwölf, ist
es, ist sechs
kleiner vierzehn ist es, und zwei ist kleiner
dreizehn ist es auch, also wäre
das erste Spiel
okay.
So, und hier jetzt guck, hier zieht er
zum Beispiel fünfzehn blaue Würfel,
das wäre nicht möglich,
weil es größer als vierzehn ist.
Ja.
Ich glaube, soweit
so gut.
Okay, jetzt kriegen wir das nochmal
erklärt.
Game eins, zwei und
fünf sind possible, ja, das
eins possible haben wir schon gesehen.
Zwei ist auch possible, alles
deutlich kleiner als zwölf, dreizehn
oder vierzehn. Game drei
ist nicht possible, weil zwanzig
rote Würfel gibt es nicht.
Ja, genau.
Game vier geht nicht, weil
fünfzehn blaue,
und Game
fünf erzählen sich schon mal gar nichts zu.
Okay.
Ach, okay.
If you add up the IDs of the games,
then would have possible you get eight.
Okay, also wir brauchen die ID,
und die ID müssen wir dann quasi
eine Summe drüber bilden,
und das ist wahrscheinlich
unser Lösungscode
vermutlich.
Ja, okay.
Ich glaube, ich habe es verstanden. Chat,
habt ihr es auch verstanden?
Ich glaube, soweit passt.
Excellent.
Okay.
Auf geht's.
Ich würde
vorschlagen, wir...
Ne, komm, fang gleich mit dem ganzen an.
Du würdest
das mit Async machen.
Hä? Inwieweit hat
Async jetzt irgendwas damit zu tun?
Du meinst, die
Zeilen parallel durch
suchen und nicht nacheinander?
Oder, oder was?
So, ah, Quatsch.
Wir brauchen
hier in der Datei nochmal
input.txt,
machen wir wieder das gleiche wie das letzte Mal.
Letzte Zeile weg.
100 Zeilen haben wir
mit Games drin. Okay.
Dann machen wir doch mal
das gleiche wie
letztes Mal. Das können wir uns kurz
copy-pasten.
Also, input. Gucken wir mal.
Schauen wir mal, ob alles funktioniert.
For each
line in input.
Line. Schauen wir mal, ob es funzt.
Ob alles läuft.
Yep. Funzt.
Das ist nicht Kreisel-Crined.
Kreisel-Crined, wenn ihr wollt,
können wir heute Abend wieder machen.
Ich muss mir noch ein Shummy leveln.
Ich muss noch mein Skalde fertig ausrüsten.
Und ich muss noch meine Hexe
ein bisschen...
Ich muss noch Epic machen mit der Hexe.
Weil 50 ist die. Die ist schon 50.
Und dann muss ich noch ein bisschen PvP machen.
Bäschen, Alter. Bäschen.
Okay. So.
Konzentrieren. Was
müssen wir jetzt machen?
Würde mit Async machen. Wegen IoT.
Alles klar.
Ja.
Und wann machst du Big Data?
Und wann wird diagonal skaliert, um die
Synergie-Effekte zu nutzen?
Und wann gibt's die passende Blockchain-Lösung?
Genau.
Ich...
Ich sehe...
Ich sehe, der Chat...
Der Chat ist im Business-Enterprise-Modus.
Gerade schon wieder.
Man könnte quasi sagen,
der Chat ist im Stonks-Modus.
Die Leute nicht zu sehr mit technischen Details verwirren.
Das...
Wir wissen...
Also, wenn wir eins aus YouTube und Community-Gruppe gelernt haben,
ist es, dass man eigentlich nichts können muss.
Man braucht nur das richtige Mindset.
Der Rest geht von alleine.
Ihr müsst euch informieren können.
Ihr müsst euch mit Technik nicht auskennen.
Ihr braucht einfach nur das richtige Mindset.
Das wird...
Das ist quasi das richtige Grindset-Mindset.
Sozusagen.
Das richtige Grindset haben wir nachher auch.
Dann werden wir eine Runde Kreisel grinden wieder.
So. Einmal jetzt Chat.
Ruhig jetzt. Hier.
Mit Business-Enterprise-Stells.
Ja.
Auf jeden Fall musst du aufstehen.
Und du musst dir die Biografie von Elon Musk kaufen,
dass du...
was du tun kannst.
Ich bin der neue Elon Musk für...
bei irgendeiner
hessischen Drei-Mann-Klitsche.
Und nicht nur einmal.
Okay. Also. Auf geht's.
Was wollen die jetzt?
Was wollen die jetzt von uns?
Community-Ge...
So. Wir machen das jetzt mal so hier.
Wir kopieren uns das mal raus,
damit man das merken kann,
wo die Limits sind.
Also.
Wir bekommen pro Zeile,
dass, ich will sagen,
der erste Step ist,
in jeder Zeile
rauszupasen,
was
die höchste Anzahl an Würfel ist.
Dazu machen wir
erstmal Regex-Magic.
Gucken, ob das...
Gucken, ob mir da ein guter Regex für einfällt.
Also.
Regex.
Wir suchen etwas, das besteht aus
Digits,
Leerzeichen und dann
eine Farbe.
Gut. Das ist eigentlich relativ einfach.
Digit, Leerzeichen und dann irgendeine Farbe.
Red, Green, Blue.
Ne. Red, Blue, Green.
Es ist egal, die Reihenfolge.
Aber ich finde Red, Blue, Green kann ich irgendwie besser merken.
So. Das ist im Prinzip...
Aha. Moment. Error.
Wer sieht den Fehler in meinem Regex-Chatge?
Wer ist...
Wer...
Wer ist... Ok. Ihr wollt Green zuerst, meinetwegen.
Was ist der Fehler in meinem Regex?
Ja, doch. Leider. Regex.
Müssen wir jetzt durch. Was ist der Fehler in meinem Regex?
Ihr kennt ja den alten Spruch.
Willst du ein Problem mit Regex
lösen, dann hast du zwei Probleme.
Richtig, Theo.
Das hier kann mehr als
1 sein, weil es kann ja
durchaus auf 15 gezogen werden.
Korrekt.
Aber es kommt auf jeden Fall immer ein Leerzeichen.
Wir können sogar ganz
high IQ sein und
White Space-Character benutzen an der Stelle.
Massive.
Alles klar. So.
Regex.
Matches.
Schauen wir mal, was da rauskommt.
Äh. Chapter.
Wie viele Matches haben wir denn hier jetzt?
Einige.
Das scheint schon mal halbwegs zu funktionieren.
Moment. Moment.
Nee, nee, nee.
Ich brauche noch eine Gruppe um die
Digits, damit ich darauf zugreifen kann
später.
Okay.
Das sollte doch jetzt so funzen.
Jetzt schauen wir mal, was mein Regex geregext hat.
Ich habe noch eine andere Idee.
Zum Regex basteln, was immer
ziemlich nice ist.
Nehmen wir mal die Zeile hier zum Beispiel.
Regex Lab.
Da kann man zum Beispiel hier seinen Input reinkopieren.
Das meinte ich übrigens auch.
Regex 101.
Das ist das, was ich gesucht habe.
Hieß das früher nicht mal Regex Lab?
Das ist das, was ich auch gesucht habe.
So.
Und jetzt mal unseren Regex
reinkopieren.
Und man sieht,
das funktioniert.
Wir matchen
Digits.
Gefolgt von
White Spaces.
Gefolgt von Rot, oder Grün,
oder Blau.
Also man sieht auch hier, wird gematcht.
Match 1, Match 2,
Match 3,
bis Match 18.
Das scheint zu funktionieren.
Vielleicht kann ich auch noch die
ID matchen. Das wäre natürlich super
Massive Premium.
Wenn wir die ID da noch irgendwie,
sagen wir mal, Zeilen beginnt mit Game,
geht dann weiter
mit
Digit,
Doppelpunkt, Leerzeichen.
Ach nee.
Das funktioniert jetzt ja an der Stelle
natürlich nicht mehr.
Weil das dann alles in der richtigen Reihenfolge
kommen muss und nicht mehrfach drinnen vorkommen
kann.
Um das zu fixen könnte
man das jetzt theoretisch
klammern
und ein oder davor machen.
Oh fuck, Alter.
Leute, ich glaube,
ich glaube es funzt.
Ich glaube High IQ Rekkex hat zugeschlagen
hier. Alles
klar. Warum ist
Rekkex immer so unleserlich, Mann?
Okay, jetzt lasst uns mal kurz checken, ob das
Sinn ergibt. Das heißt Match 0,
Match 0 sollte eigentlich
immer die ID sein.
Äh,
Moment, Moment. Nein, nicht Match 0.
Ja doch.
Oh fuck.
Ach, Krupp.
Krupp, okay.
Match 0
und was ist Match 1?
Ah ja, das.
Aber, aber ich habe doch das hier auch
gecaptured.
Jetzt. Oh fuck.
Okay, das.
Und da habe ich jetzt Krupps.
5, okay.
Hey, Funz, nice, guck mal.
Okay, Match 0.
Das ist egal,
ob wir das auch so gepasst hätten.
So, das hier ist die ID.
Ich hoffe, ich hoffe, dass heute
die Zeilen nicht gefaked, also
letztes Mal war das Problem, dass im Input
Syntaxfehler drin waren. Ich hoffe,
diesmal sind keine Syntaxfehler drin.
Weil wenn absichtliche Syntaxfehler eingebaut wurden,
bin ich ziemlich, ziemlich gearscht, ja.
Okay, das ist die ID.
Sag mal, int, pass.
Das ist die ID.
So,
dann geht es weiter.
Dann geht es weiter mit Matches.
So, und jetzt, jetzt, jetzt,
ähm, okay.
Oh ne, jetzt brauche ich eine zweite Schleife.
Haha, wahrscheinlich hätte ich es echt
einfacher von Hand gepasst, Alter.
Ähm,
Matches. So, jetzt müssen wir mal
.NET Magic benutzen. Wir wollen alles
ähm, von 1
bis Ende. Oh ne, wie ging das jetzt
nochmal? Ne.
Moment, bin verwirrt. Wie war
da die richtige Syntax für nochmal?
0 gleich Matches.
War das Funst?
Das weiß ich. Konnte man, konnte man nicht
sagen 1 bis Ende?
Ne, scheint nicht.
Ähm, okay.
C sharp range Syntax. Wie ging das
jetzt nochmal? Ranges.
Beispiel Microsoft.
Beispiel, please.
Doch. Ne, ne,
ich habe mehrere Matches.
Äh, das Funst irgendwie nicht.
To array, bam.
Jawoll, nice.
Ihr habt recht, das geht nur auf
Arrays. Also,
Matches von 1
bis
weil das erste wollen wir ja nicht mehr.
Das erste
ist ja unsere ID.
Ähm, hier Match.
Oh, Match.
Jetzt gucken wir mal, was das ausspuckt.
Wir breaken mal nach der ersten Zeile,
dass ich es irgendwie checke.
Okay, 19 blue, 12 red,
blue, 2 green.
Sicher?
Tatsächlich.
Das scheint zu stimmen, Leute.
19 blue, 12 red,
19 blue, 2 green.
Ja, ich denke, ich denke,
ich denke, das stimmt.
Guckt mal hier. Ja.
19 blue, 12 red,
19 blue, 2 green,
1 red, 13 red,
ja, ja, ja.
Okay, Regex Magic hat gesiegt.
Jetzt müssen wir mal gucken,
wie wir dort
Erkennst
du denn die Semikolons? Nö, muss ich auch
gar nicht.
Es ist, das ist eigentlich egal
an der Stelle. Ich muss einfach nur rechnen, was
die höchste Anzahl an blauen,
die höchste Anzahl an grünen und die höchste
Anzahl an roten ist.
Es ist, glaube ich, zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt,
vielleicht brauchen wir das für Step 2.
Ja, die Aufgabe ist
wieder richtig übertrieben
geschrieben so, damit da ganz viele Informationen
die dich eigentlich gar nicht interessieren müssen.
Okay.
Jetzt
muss ich was machen?
Jetzt muss ich den ganzen Krempel
zusammenzählen, korrekt?
Also, ich habe jetzt
ein Regex,
in dem Regex,
da habe ich jetzt Groups.
Und was steht in welchen Groups drinnen?
Was steht in Group 1 drinnen?
Das komplette in Group 2
nichts
und in Group 3?
Moment, in Group 3 stehen jetzt die
und in Group 4?
Okay, whatever.
Gruppe 3
und 4 ist es.
Was macht Regex?
Okay, das ist
unglaublich schwierig in zwei Sätzen zu erklären,
was Regex macht.
Mit Regex kannst du Text
untersuchen, ob es gewissen
einer gewissen
Logik
Wie kann man
Regex in zwei Sätzen erklären, Leute?
Mit Regex
kannst du Textinput überprüfen,
ob es einem gewissen Muster folgt.
Ich glaube, das ist das
kürzeste und knackigste, was mir so einfällt.
Kannst gucken,
ob dein Textinput
einem bestimmten Muster entspricht.
Und diese
Syntax, um dieses Muster
anzugeben, das ist allgemein
das, was man
unter
Regex versteht. Also zum Beispiel,
was der Regex hier oben bedeutet ist,
am Anfang der Zeile
übrigens der
Ne, doch, das brauche ich.
Am Anfang der Zeile
muss das Wort Game stehen.
Leerzeichen.
Danach muss eine beliebige
Zahl kommen, beliebig
oft hintereinander, gefolgt
von einem Doppelpunkt.
Also wenn du dir hier den Input anguckst, siehst du auch,
so ist die Zeile aufgebaut.
Das heißt, das Match steht drauf. Zeile start mit Game,
Leerzeichen
und dann kommt
eine Zahl, beliebig oft, weil es muss
ja auch sowas wie 10 und nicht nur 1 gematcht werden.
Wenn ich das Plus hier weglassen
würde, dann würde der immer nur hier eine 1,
dann würde es nicht mehr matchen.
Man muss ihm sagen, okay, es kann
eine beliebige Zahl kommen,
beliebig oft,
hintereinander.
Allerdings der Unterschied zwischen Plus und Sternchen,
Chat, Pfeifert Regex
Kenner. Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt,
wer es weiß.
Das wäre in dem Fall der Unterschied zwischen Sternchen
und Plus.
D gilt für Digit, genau.
Also eine Zahl im Endeffekt. Ich glaube, ich habe sogar eine Hilfe,
wenn ich hier drüber bewege.
Ey, habe ich nicht.
Ja, korrekt.
Der Chat weiß Bescheid.
Siehst du, Community
High IQ heute.
Richtig. Der Unterschied ist,
Plus bedeutet,
es muss mindestens einmal vorkommen,
beliebig oft, also
bis beliebig oft.
Genau, man könnte das auch noch mit
Klammern, mit geschweiften Klammern dahinter
machen, wobei
ich das eigentlich nur benutze für, wenn ich sagen
will, 1 bis 3 oder so.
Ja, also bei IPs zum Beispiel.
Also, Plus
sagt, es muss quasi
1 bis
unendlich vorkommen
und Sternchen
würde sagen, 0 bis
unendlich. Das heißt,
Sternchen heißt auch immer,
es wäre erlaubt, dass
nichts dasteht an der Stelle.
Und Sternchen
machen in der Regel eure Regexe kaputt.
Nicht, dass ich das nicht auch an jeder
Ecke verwenden würde, aber meistens ist das so
besser. So.
Also, auf geht's.
Group 3 ist
der Count
und was war
und Group 4
ist die Color, oder? Sehe ich das richtig?
Group 4 ist die Color.
War Color gleich.
So.
Schauen wir mal, ob das jetzt passt oder ob es irgendwo
crasht. Ich spüre es einfach mal aus.
Wenn es nicht crasht, scheint es... Okay, gut.
Achso, Moment. Ich sollte mal das Break ausmachen.
So, mal gucken, ob es irgendwo
crasht.
Gut, gut. Scheint zumindest
alles syntaktisch richtig zu sein.
Dann würde ich sagen, wir machen es
jetzt
ein bisschen advancer und zwar
wir machen dann eine Link-Expression
draus.
Und zwar sagen wir Matches von 1
bis zum letzten Element
Select
Match
und das hier
lassen wir das mal raus. So.
Das transformieren wir in
ein neues Objekt.
Und zwar
mit
M ist es
dann nur noch.
Das transformieren wir in ein neues
Objekt mit
nennen wir das mal hier irgendwie
Result.
Mit einer Variable Color.
Dann...
Oh fuck, wie macht man das denn jetzt?
Moment,
Moment. Freehead.
Du kannst den Groups auch Namen geben. Ja, das
geht auch irgendwie. Ich glaube,
ich glaube, du kannst irgendwie
so, irgendwie kann man Namen machen.
Aber...
Weiß ich aus dem Kopf nicht. Das haben wir
letztes Mal ja probiert.
In C Sharp hat sich tatsächlich vieles getan.
Also das, was du 2017 programmiert hast,
geht heute auch noch. Aber sie haben einige
neue Sachen drinne schon.
Ja, du kannst zum Beispiel jetzt sowas hier machen.
Record. Cag.
Und da sagst du
int a
int b.
Das ist so eines der neueren Aushänge
Features, was Microsoft immer
immer wieder betont und bewirbt.
So, und wenn du sowas hier hast
und das ausgibst,
dann kannst du es quasi so anlegen
und wenn du es ausgibst, ist auch
quasi überschrieben, dass du eine gescheite Konsolenausgabe
kriegst.
Und es ist auch überschrieben
equals, dass das und das
gleich ist.
Weil bei Klassen wäre das ja nicht, also bei normalen
Reference Types wäre das ja nicht so.
Ja, das ist eigentlich ganz
sinnig, was sie da gebaut haben.
Aber nicht alle Features, aber nicht alle Features
sind nice. Da sind auch ein paar
echt bisschen, weiß nicht,
unfertige, beziehungsweise
was soll ich sagen,
nicht zu Ende gedacht dabei gewesen
die letzten Jahre.
Genau, und außerdem, dass man ein Top Level, da habe ich gar nicht mehr
dran gedacht, genau, dass man ein Top Level
Programm schreiben kann, ohne
Programm Main, ist auch relativ neu.
Wobei man dazu
sagen muss, unter der Haube ist es immer noch
das gleiche, nur dass der Compiler
für dich das quasi das
Main drum herum generiert.
So, also.
Wir müssen jetzt
nur, dass ich, Chat, nur dass ich
weiter durchblicke. Wir haben uns jetzt
rausgeholt, die Anzahl
an Würfeln
pro Step
in welcher Farbe.
So. So, und das
Count, Count sollte
by the way auch ein Int sein.
Hallo?
Achso.
Int, Parse,
das muss er wahrscheinlich an ToString machen.
So.
Jetzt haben wir das,
ich bin mir jetzt etwas unschlüssig.
Gibt es jetzt Sinn, was ich hier
gemacht habe?
Okay, bis jetzt scheint es zu funktionieren.
So, also.
Okay, Link Magic, Leute, Link Magic.
Wir haben alle
Würfel pro Step und die Anzahl.
Das heißt, jetzt müssen wir
raussuchen, was
jetzt gucken wir
nochmal den Input an,
was die höchste Anzahl
von Würfeln pro Farbe
pro, ja,
pro Zeile, pro Game ist.
Also
in dem Fall hier 19,
äh, 13,
2,
müsste dann da rauskommen.
Okay, ich hab, ich hab
eine Idee. Ich hab eine Idee.
Ähm, könnten wir,
ich mein, die, die
ein, ups, die einfachste Sache
wäre,
zu sagen, irgendwie
Red gleich
Result
Wear,
was ist das? Ja, Würfel.
Ähm, Wear
Color gleich
gleich Red,
wobei das bestimmt noch einfacher geht.
Und dann
Max Counts.
So, und da müsste ich jetzt
die höchste Anzahl von roten Würfeln immer
rauskriegen, aber das ist doof. Das ist
so, so, so doppelt gemoppelt alles.
Das gefällt mir, gefällt mir
nicht.
Aber funktionieren
würde es so höchstwahrscheinlich.
Hm.
Ah, Chat.
Ich hab eine Idee. Ich hab eine Idee.
Pass mal auf. Six Head Mode.
Six Head Mode. Ich hoffe,
das funktioniert. Pass mal auf.
Group by,
ähm,
Group by
Color.
Ich muss das grad nochmal ausgeben, sonst check ich's wieder nicht.
Ach, das checkt er mal wieder.
Alter, geil. Nice.
Okay, Group
by Color.
Von der Idee her kommt jetzt da so eine
Art Dictionary
Hash Map raus.
Nee, kommt nicht.
Da kommt jetzt eine lange Liste
raus mit,
was? Ich muss mal kurz checken,
was kommt da jetzt? Result, Count,
Length,
Count. Kommt jetzt da 3
raus oder mehr? 3!
Okay, dann ergibt es, dann ergibt
es tatsächlich Sinn.
Gibt es auch Group by?
Ja, ja,
hab ich da hier.
Nee, sowas, das ist ja kein SQL.
So, wartet mal.
Group by Color.
Und jetzt,
und jetzt kann ich jetzt sowas sagen,
wie, also das
benutze ich auch sehr selten. Kann ich jetzt sowas
sagen? Oder, okay, warte mal. Es gibt
Max by?
Oh, das ist auch gut.
Nee.
Ah!
The fuck?
Moment. Wie ist das jetzt?
Was habe ich denn hier überhaupt?
Key.
Ach, Value ist das hier. Okay.
Ah ja, das würde funktionieren,
aber das ist ja nicht das, was ich haben
will.
Ist ja nicht das, was ich haben will.
Ähm. Nee, Max,
das ergibt keinen Sinn. Ich weiß, was ich
haben will. Ich will to Dictionary haben.
To Dictionary.
Und da will ich jetzt haben für den
Key, will ich den
Key benutzen von der Group.
Und für den Value,
für den
Value will ich
äh, ähm,
Max,
aber Max was?
Moment, das ist ja auch eine Group.
Das ist ja G.
Count. Hä? Heute machen wir
kein C++, das kann man vergessen.
So, äh, ja.
Äh, ergibt das Sinn?
Ergibt das in irgendeiner Art und Weise
Sinn?
Key
und dann Max
als
Ich hoffe, das funktioniert, Leute.
Ich bin mir jetzt echt unschlüssig gerade.
Das soll, also wenn es funktioniert, sollte es
jetzt ein Dictionary gegeben haben
mit Red,
mit Blue
und mit Green, okay?
Es crasht nicht.
Ich würde mal fast
vermuten, dass das funktioniert so.
Vermutlich. Mal kurz jucken.
Ähm, das sieht
sieht doch eigentlich jetzt ganz
brauchbar aus an der Stelle.
So, jetzt haben wir einen Dictionary.
Kann .NET 7 gegen C
Shop 12 kompilieren?
Ich bin mir ehrlich gerade
nicht sicher, wie genau die Abhängigkeit
ist. Also du kannst
teilweise neueren Code
kompilieren, sogar noch gegen
.NET Framework.
Aber wahrscheinlich ist es echt so, es hängt
hauptsächlich davon ab, was für Features du benutzt.
Aber solange man
.NET Core verwendet, macht es ja eigentlich kaum
den Sinn, was anderes als die neueste
.NET Core Version zu, also es heißt ja nicht
mal .NET Core, die neueste .NET Version zu
benutzen. Wenn man natürlich noch auf Framework
hängt, dann hat man
vielleicht noch mehr Probleme.
So, Chat, das ist doch fast, das ist doch
fast das, was wir haben
wollen, oder?
Fragezeichen, korrekt
Fragezeichen, also
das bedeutet doch im Endeffekt,
jetzt wollen wir gucken,
if
if, so, red
maximum red
größer
ähm
größer gleich 12
und
result blue
größer gleich
ja, machen wir green
Moment, größer gleich?
Ne
kleiner gleich
kleiner
kleiner gleich?
Kleiner gleich
ne, wir wollen gucken, ob das
ob das kleiner ist, als
die Anzahl. Aber wir wollen ja wissen, ob
quasi der Zug
möglich wäre mit einer maximalen Anzahl
von diesen Würfeln. Ok, kleiner, kleiner
gleich. Und dann
als letztes result blue
kleiner gleich 14
kek. So,
gucken wir, ob das noch ohne zu crashen funktioniert.
Ok.
Und jetzt haben wir die ID
von dem Kram.
eva cnt gleich 0
cnt plus gleich
id
äh, nicht id,
count. So,
kommt da angeblich raus.
Ich bin mal gespannt, ob
das stimmt. Wobei ich ja
sagen würde, das ist auf jeden Fall noch
nicht enterprisey genug, gell?
Die Aufgabe.
Nicht enterprise genug.
Ich würd sagen, wir sind
tatsächlich mal ordentlich. Ich hab
ne Idee. Ok, wisst ihr,
wisst ihr, was wir machen? Wir machen das
weil das ist, das könntest du 1 zu 1
so in fast jeder Programmiersprache basteln.
Ich mein, außer C++, da ist
sowas hier natürlich schwierig. Wobei ganz
ehrlich, diese Link-Geschichte,
wenn ich das in ne andere Sprache, wenn ich das hier
in ne andere Sprache übersetzen würde,
würde es wahrscheinlich trotzdem wieder ganz anders
aussehen.
Aber, wollen wir, können wir überprüfen
erst mal, ob das stimmt, was hier jetzt
rauskommt. Warte mal.
Rot kleiner 12,
grün
kleiner 13
und 14 kleiner,
äh, und blue kleiner 14. Schade zu
haben, dass das stimmt. Ok, gucken wir mal. Chat.
Abstimmung. Sekunde. Vote.
Vote.
Äh, nee, nicht
vote. Äh, prediction.
Prediction.
Start prediction.
Wird das Ergebnis stimmen?
Ja, nein. Start prediction.
Ja.
Also, ich werde das gleich in die Seite
reinhauen. Ach ja, und falls ihr
denkt, bei euch war
das, war die gleiche Zahl als
das. Das kann nicht sein, weil der Input randomized
ist. Also, ihr könnt anhand
von meiner Zahl, und selbst wenn ihr es im Vorfeld
gemacht habt, nicht ableiten, ob das stimmt oder nicht
stimmt. Nur die LTS.
Alle, jede zweite Version
ist da, ist, ist, ist da LTS,
oder? Das heißt,
jetzt kam 8, 8, ist 8
nicht wieder LTS?
8 ist wieder
LTS gewesen, gell? Und 7,
und 7 war kein LTS.
Ich glaub 5 war auch wieder LTS.
Aus Prinzip dagegen stimmen.
Vielleicht hast du recht,
vielleicht doch nicht, ich hab keine Ahnung, ob das
stimmt.
Ich werde jetzt auch nichts dazu sagen, weil das
beeinflusst die Prediction.
Ist das vordere,
das wird funktionieren?
Ah ja, das vordere wird schon funktionieren.
Ihr, ihr seid
da aber erstaunlich zu,
ja,
zuversichtlich. Ach stimmt,
.NET 6 gab's ja auch, es gab bloß .NET
4 nicht, ja, ich war grad, ich war grad verwirrt.
.NET 4 würde, das ist ja
auch wieder so eine, so eine Microsoft, Microsoft
Geschichte, ne? .NET Core
3.1, .NET, .NET
5.
Okay, also die meisten
denken, dass es funktioniert.
Okay, ich glaube
ehrlich gesagt auch, dass es
funktioniert, weil
es, also aus zwei Gründen,
das läuft ohne Fehler durch.
Normalerweise ist das ja kein guter
Indikator für, ob das korrekt ist.
Aber in dem Fall bedeutet es
zumindest, der Input
stimmt mit dem überein, was ich hier versuche
zu parsen. Was darauf
hindeutet, dass es richtig ist.
Weil wenn da irgendwas verkehrt
wäre, würd's halt einfach crashen, ja.
Und das zweite ist, dass die Nummer
irgendwie, weiß nicht,
so bauchgefühlsmäßig
ganz gut aussieht.
Es ist jetzt kein, es ist jetzt keine 5
oder so, und es ist keine 90.000
oder sowas, was zu hoch wär.
Es ist irgendwas so, ja, in der
Mitte irgendwo, und deswegen denk ich mal,
dass, okay.
Oh shit, ey, Moment.
Nee, stimmt!
Ich dachte, das ist die
Oh man, Bepega-Time.
Ich dachte, das ist die Meldung so
nach dem Motto, äh, was
steht in der Meldung, wenn's falsch ist?
Ähm, it is too low
oder it is too high, try again
oder sowas steht dann da. Easy.
Wobei so,
ganz so easy war das gar nicht.
Also das hier ist schon echt
Pepega. Aber Leute, bevor ich
auf, bevor ich mich Aufgabe 2 widme,
ich möchte
das noch etwas verenterprisen,
okay? Wir brauchen
noch ne, ne, äh,
Elf-Game-Factory-Class
oder sowas. Ich würde,
ich würde, ich würde das nämlich echt gerne
ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen schöner machen.
Was haltet ihr denn von, was haltet ihr denn
von sowas, ja? Wir machen sowas wie
Public-Class-Game.
So.
Game kriegt int
eine ID. Pff, wo
Unitests rewrite
in Java? Ja, in Kotlin
könnten wir's, ey, das ist
wirklich ne gute Idee.
Wir könnten das,
wir könnten das noch in Kotlin rewrite.
Da, da wollte ich mich eh mal ein bisschen mehr mit
beschäftigen.
So. Also wir brauchen, guck mal,
ja, wir, wir, wir
brauchen ne Class, ne, ne, ne Klasse Game
und ich, ich, ich
würde, ich würde sagen,
wir machen jetzt da sowas wie hier, Public
Static
Game Pass.
So. Und das kriegt dann als
Input den String.
Und hier drinnen machen wir das dann.
Gibt's kein Payout.
Achso. Doch. Mod, Modge.
Modge, please. Payout.
Prediction.
Mod, Modgetime.
So. Game
Pass.
Dann packen wir nämlich das hier
da rein.
Das kommentieren wir mal aus.
Packen wir das
hier rein. So. Der,
der Regex,
der kommt hier rein.
So. Wobei den Regex könnte
man eigentlich Static machen,
aber wurscht. Der Regex kommt
hier rein. Regex
Matches.
So. Und da gibt's jetzt Return
New Game.
Mit einer,
ups, uh,
mit einer ID.
Ah, und jetzt brauchen
wir noch, jetzt brauchen wir noch für die
Anzahl,
ähm, Int, nennen wir's
MaxBlue.
Ups.
Red.
Green.
Blue ist Result.
Blue.
Red.
Green.
Green. Okay.
Oh, jetzt haben wir das, jetzt haben wir's schon wieder viel
nicer verenterpriced.
Und jetzt können wir hier oben sagen, wobei,
wir können das jetzt wirklich, wir können das
jetzt tatsächlich damit wirklich viel, viel
schicker machen. Wir können jetzt sowas hier sagen
wie, ähm,
irgendwie,
Result.
Result ist immer die, der beste,
also, Result ist der, der, das Enterprise
Naming für Temp, ja.
Normalerweise machen sie, aber wenn man nicht weiß,
was es ist, immer Result, einfach immer Result
nennen. Irgendein Result ist es
ja logischerweise, sonst wird's nicht funktionieren.
Welches Result, ja, das steht wieder
auf dem anderen Blatt.
Also, jetzt sagen wir einfach mal
Input, Select,
Line, so,
New Game, wird das jetzt gepasst?
Äh,
nicht nur New Game, was mach ich denn hier?
Game Pass
Line
und dann können wir
sagen, ähm,
wartet mal,
Where,
ne, sowas, sowas
in der Richtung, Where,
Game, Max
Blue ist kleiner,
Max Red
ist kleiner, gleich
und, und
Game Max
Green ist kleiner, gleich
13 und,
und Game,
Max Red ist kleiner, gleich
12 und dann
Sum.
Das ist doch schon mal deutlich, Moment, Sekunde.
Das stimmt ja nicht.
Game, nur die, nur die Summe
von der ID.
So, ich hoffe, da kommt jetzt das
Gleiche raus, nachdem ich
verenterprisiert habe.
Shit.
Mist.
Nicht genug verenterprisiert,
Alter.
Was? Irgendwo hab ich mich vertippt.
Leute, wo hab ich mich vertippt?
Blue, Red, Green.
Oh. Äh, Blue.
Ey, wir sind tatsächlich noch
bei Tag 2.
Okay, das ist schon besser.
Schon besser, schon besser.
Ja, ja.
Was hat er hier?
Convert to Group. Oh, das ist ne gute Idee.
Nice.
Leute, ich hab noch, ich hab noch ne Idee.
Wir verenterprisen das jetzt noch mehr.
Ich hab, ich hab ne Idee.
Passt mal auf, passt mal auf.
Passt mal auf. Wir machen das jetzt so, wir machen das jetzt so.
Public
Rule is
Valid Game.
This. Where.
Äh, wait a minute.
Ich wollte eigentlich ne Methode
da draus machen. So.
Is Valid Game.
Kann man, kann man das, kann man das, sag ich mal.
Geht das immer noch?
Hey, das funktioniert immer noch.
Okay. Bis das, bis das Ende
Enterprise Approvement ist, ist in Sicht.
Und
jetzt, jetzt kommt, Leute.
Jetzt kommt, jetzt kommt der, der
Top Enterprise
Step überhaupt.
Das heißt, er rechnet das, er rechnet das jedes Mal
aus. Ja, korrekt.
Ja. Er rechnet das jedes Mal
aus. Wir, wir könnten das tatsächlich
auch initiat... Du, du hast, du hast,
du hast recht, du hast recht.
Das ist eigentlich total dumm, was ich hier mache.
Es müsste eigentlich,
müsste sowas hier geben.
Property Bool
Is Valid.
Du hast vollkommen recht.
Is Valid Game.
Dass das nur private gesettet werden kann.
Und jetzt wird das, wird, wird hier gesetzt.
Das wird, das wird hier.
Ah, das, das ist jetzt aber blöd.
Ne, da hab ich das
noch nicht belegt.
Aber ist ja wurscht.
Game.
Das muss ja auch nicht belegt sein.
Dings. Klar.
Ups. Return Game.
Ja.
Eigentlich ganz, eigentlich ganz okay.
Ja. Das, das,
das hat doch, das hat doch was.
Und
kommt immer noch das gleiche raus? Ja.
Tatsächlich. Leute, nein,
nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Kommando zurück.
Kommando zurück. Pass auf.
Enterprise Business Tactics.
Ich hab noch ne bessere Idee.
Pass auf. Noch, noch ne
bessere, noch ne bessere Idee. Wir lassen,
wir lassen, dass das, wir lassen, dass das ne Methode
ist. Okay? Aber
passt mal auf, passt mal auf.
Public. Record.
Game Limit.
Int.
Limit Green.
Limit Red.
Int. Limit Blue.
Jetzt wird's richtig pfeifert.
Ähm.
Game Limit.
So. Limit.
Und jetzt, und jetzt. Hier.
Ähm. Limit Red.
Limit Green.
Ich hoffe, ich schreib das
jetzt nix verkehrt. Limit Red, Limit Green
und, und
Limit Blue.
So. Und jetzt
können wir sagen,
war Config
gleich, nee.
Doch, New, äh, nee, nicht Config.
Wie hab ich's genannt?
Hier. Äh, Limit.
New Game
Limit. So.
Und jetzt machen wir Green.
Warte mal. 12, 13,
14. Und jetzt muss es noch
richtig heißen. Das erste
ist Red. Nee, wow.
Oh, ich bin.
Red.
Green, Blue.
So. Massive Nice
Enterprise.
Und es kommt immer noch das gleiche raus.
So ist gut, oder? Jetzt ist es,
jetzt ist es Enterprise as fuck.
Jetzt, so kann man das, so kann man
das lassen.
So finde ich das gut.
Excellent, excellent, excellent.
Jetzt brauchen wir aber, jetzt brauchen wir eigentlich
das hier gar nicht mehr.
Guck mal, jetzt brauchen wir das nicht mehr.
High IQ
Refactoring. Ähm.
Brauchen wir das nicht mehr?
Zu, äh,
nee, äh, Moment.
Kann ich das nicht einfach,
kann ich dem nicht einfach sagen, wandle das
please um?
Ja, egal, meinetwegen, dann.
Komm, scheiß drauf. Wir lassen's einfach.
So.
Alles klar. So, ich würde sagen,
genug Enterprise Business.
Enterprise gleich umständlich.
Nee, nicht zwangsläufig.
Aber meistens auf jeden Fall etwas
mehr bloated.
Rust. Vielleicht machen wir
auch Rust. Also,
ich hatte tatsächlich vor, das in Bash zu machen
nachher. Wobei,
wenn ich mir das so recht angucke,
mal gucken, ob da mein, meine,
mein Bash High IQ genug für ist.
Okay, Chat, Frage an euch.
Was,
was fandet ihr schöner lesbar?
Die, die,
die Enterprise Business Variante?
Oder einfach nur
drei Zeilen, drei, äh, irgendwie nur
zehn Zeilen? Ich mein, das ist schon
ein bisschen aufwendiger geworden, ne?
Also, was, was findet ihr besser?
Das oder...
Weiß ja nicht, ob ich,
ob ich überhaupt, ah, fuck, ich komme gar nicht mehr so
weit zurück. Wart mal.
Wartet mal.
Äh, History.
Das
oder...
Ähm, bin gar nicht sicher.
Wo, wo war, wo hatten wir es denn?
Hier. Das oder das.
Also, 30 Zeilen
versus Business Enterprise.
Was für einen Maus-Cursor
hast du? Das ist...
Bibata Modern Ember.
30 Zeilen.
War es auch. War es auch.
Ne, komm, wir lassen es jetzt so. So ist gut.
Enterprise Business.
Na, wiederverwenden will ich davon ja eigentlich
nix. Wir lassen es jetzt so.
Chat, wir halten uns da nicht so
lang dran auf. Wir lassen es jetzt. Genug.
Genug.
Dokus und Tests, Alter.
Findet ihr nicht,
dass das selbstdokumentierend ist?
Also, also ich, ich find schon,
das ist, das ist so klar
alles geschrieben, das dokumentiert
sich selbst, ne?
Und nachdem es keine Fehler hat, brauchen wir
auch keine Tests, weil ich will ja...
Warum soll ich was, was nicht kaputt ist, testen?
Ja, ne?
Ich mein, vor allem, wenn es funktioniert.
Ich muss ja nix testen, was funktioniert.
Das ist ja overrated.
Und Kommentare brauchen wir auch nicht,
weil es sich selbst kommentiert.
Okay, gut. Fertig.
Mit Aufgabe 1.
Weiter geht's.
0, 2, 1...
Ne, Moment.
Okay, Quade.
0, 2...
2.
Kommt jetzt.
Ich copy-paste mir das mal, weil ich davon ausgehe,
wir brauchen da bestimmt Teile davon wieder.
0, 2, 2.
New Console.
Open. Nein.
So, weil ich das Falsche angeklickt hab jetzt, ey.
0, 2.
Okay. Trust.
This Window.
So, wir copy-pasten das rein.
Wir kopieren uns den Text-Output
oder Input
vom Alten auch noch hier rein.
Gucken.
Ob der Kram hier drinnen auch noch läuft.
Macht er.
So, und jetzt gucken wir uns Aufgabe 2 an.
Aufgabe 2.
Continue Part 2.
Oje, wat?
Ich ahne Schlimmes, Leute.
Ich ahne Schlimmes.
Okay.
Also das ist alles wieder Story-Text,
den man nicht braucht.
As you continue...
In each game you played,
what is the fewest
number of cubes of each color?
Jetzt.
Moment.
Also quasi jetzt...
Ich muss erst mal ganz lesen.
That could have
been in the bag to make the game
possible. What?
Was wollen die von mir?
Was die kleinste Anzahl
an Würfeln
von jeder Farbe ist,
die in der
Tüte sein
könnte?
Die kleinste Anzahl ist, dass die Tüte...
Achso! To make the game possible.
To make... Ich wollte gerade sagen, meine Tüte könnte
halt 0 sein. Seriously, Leute.
Leute, ohne Scheiß. Ich habe gerade
für einen Bruchteil
einer Sekunde geglaubt,
wir können jetzt einfach schreiben,
ähm...
Right line 0.
Ich dachte eigentlich,
die wollten mich gerade verarschen, aber...
Nein, wollen sie nicht. Okay.
That it makes the game possible.
Again consider the example
games from earlier. Okay.
Game... Was? Moment.
In game 1 the game could have been
played with as few as
4 red, 2
green and 6
blue. What?
If any
color had even one
fewer cube... Ich verstehe nicht,
was die von mir wollen.
Game 2
could have been played with a minimum
of 1 red, 3 green
and 4 blue cubes.
One red?
Hä?
Ich verstehe nicht mal, was die von mir wollen.
The power of a set of
cubes...
The power of a set of cubes is equal to
the number of red, green and blue cubes
multiplied together.
The power of the minimum set of cubes
in game 1 is...
Okay, okay, okay.
Im ersten Spiel bedeutet es
4 mal 2
mal 6.
Ja?
Richtig? Also 8
mal 6 ist 48.
Ja, das stimmt ja auch.
Aber ich verstehe überhaupt nicht, was die von mir wollen
hier. Ist das wieder viel
Text um nichts? Kann das sein?
Ja?
Ich hab's aber immer noch
nicht verstanden, was die jetzt von mir
wollen. Also ich hab gelesen, dass ihr
geschrieben habt, man kann einfach die höchste Anzahl
zusammenrechnen, okay, aber
multiplizieren. Aber warum?
Wie kommt man bei dieser Fragestellung
darauf? Achso!
Moment, Moment,
Moment. Das ist das erste
Game? Was ist das zweite?
Ah, wie kommt... Chat,
wie kommt ihr denn auf die höchste
Anzahl pro Würfel pro
Step? Ich hätte jetzt gesagt, die
wollen die Mindestanzahl der
Würfel haben. Achso!
Jetzt hab ich's verstanden!
Die Mindestanzahl
der Würfel von jeder Zeile.
Das... Oh Gott, das ist ja
super um die Ecke geschrieben, Alter!
Das ist ja... Das ist absichtlich
das G-Bait, oder?
Das ist ja super um die Ecke geschrieben.
Ich glaube, jetzt hab ich's verstanden.
Die niedrigste Anzahl der Würfel
von jeder Farbe bedeutet
im Endeffekt, ich muss die maximale
Anzahl der Würfel von
jeder Farbe wieder raussuchen.
Alter, ist das dreimal...
Boah! Das ist... Okay, das ist
absichtlich kompliziert geschrieben.
Das ist... Das ist absichtlich kompliziert
geschrieben, oder?
Was zum Teufel?
Exakt so guck ich auch. Ich weiß
noch nicht, ob ich der ganzen Sache grad trauen soll.
Sus-K-A-Kriege.
The power of the sand of cubes is equal to the number
of red, green and blue cubes... Okay.
Okay.
Heißt... Heißt im Endeffekt...
Nur, dass ich das... Nur, dass ich das jetzt richtig
verstehe.
Wir lassen alles so, wie's ist,
aber
multiplizieren alle Würfel
miteinander.
Also...
Also im Prinzip anstatt dem where
sagen wir einfach hier nur select
game
red
mal game
Ich mach das jetzt hauptsächlich auch, weil
der Chat so wirkt, als weiß er, was er schreibt.
Äh...
Green und dann...
Ach nee, Moment. Was sollen wir denn jetzt machen?
Adding up these five... Okay.
Und jetzt sollen wir den ganzen Krempel hier
summieren am Essen halt. Okay.
Sixty nine. Das kann ja schon mal
nicht falsch sein.
Neunundsechzigtausendsechshundertneunundzwanzig.
Leute,
ich hab absolut keine Ahnung, ob das
richtig ist, was ich gemacht hab.
Ich hab das... Ich hab das hauptsächlich
gemacht, weil der Chat geschrieben hat,
einfach die Dinger zusammenzählen.
Ja...
Sixty nine
for twenty wär besser. Das stimmt schon.
Du verstehst den Code nicht.
Das liegt daran, weil das Business
Enterprise Code ist.
Den können nur Business Enterprise
Engineers verstehen.
Ich hab es extra mehr Business Enterprise
gemacht heute.
Am Anfang war das eigentlich auch nur ne
Schleife und ne Variable, wo hochgezählt
wurde. Aber mir war das
nicht Business Enterprise genug.
Die ursprüngliche Variante hättste
wahrscheinlich auch einfacher ver... Also ich kann's
jetzt ha... Verdammt, lieber Hund.
Es ist im Prinzip tatsächlich relativ
relativ easy, was passiert. Also, wir
haben ne Input-Datei
mit diesen Zeilen drinne.
So, die müssen wir parsen.
Jede Zeile besteht am Anfang aus ner Game ID
und dann verschiedenen
Steps mit der Anzahl von Würfeln, die
gezogen werden. So. Das parsen
wir im Endeffekt. Wir holen uns als erstes
aus der Zeile die ID raus.
Dann holen wir uns
danach raus, hier mit diesem Magic Regex,
quasi immer die Kombination aus
19 blue, 12
red, 19 blue, 2 green.
Und davon suchen wir uns dann
aus der jeweiligen Zeile
die höchste Anzahl an blauen
Würfeln, höchste Anzahl an zwölf... an
roten Würfeln und höchste Anzahl an
grünen Würfeln raus, die in dieser Zeile
vorkommt.
Ja.
Und das, und das
merken wir uns im Endeffekt nur.
Und dann wird überprüft, ob
die maximale Anzahl
an roten Würfeln kleiner 12 ist,
die maximale Anzahl an grünen Würfeln kleiner
13, die maximale Anzahl an blauen Würfeln kleiner
14. So, das war Aufgabe 1.
Und in Aufgabe 2
muss ich, soweit es aussieht, nur alle
Max-Würfel miteinander multiplizieren.
Hier wird nix
Debugger rant.
Als Formel ausgedrückt, rote Würfel
Max aus Spiel 1 bis N.
Alles klar. Mal grüne Würfel
Max aus Spiel 1. Excellent.
Heute Chat wieder
besonders
viele Prime-Sub IQ-Punkte
gesammelt. Okay.
Dann testen wir doch mal, ob das funktioniert. Bam.
Zack. Submit.
Easy. Easy.
Das hätte ich aber ohne Chat
diesmal nicht gecheckt, ehrlich gesagt.
Easy as fuck. Easy
as fuck. Easy.
Easy.
Das hätte ich
ohne den Chat jetzt aber
echt nicht kapiert.
Wie könnte
man sowas denn...
Das können wir wegmachen.
Das brauchen wir für das zweite nicht.
Das können wir auch
wegmachen. Das brauchen wir auch für die zweite
Aufgabe nicht.
Okay. Nice.
Dann committen wir das mal, würde ich
sagen.
Git-Status
Git-Jit
Fit-Ad
Day2
So, dann gucken, ob ich nicht irgendwelche komischen
Line-Endings wieder committet habe.
Nee, habe ich nicht.
Alles gut. Das fixe ich jetzt nicht.
Dass da unsinnige
Whitespaces sind. Das darf ruhig so
bleiben. Okay.
Day2. Nice.
Push.
Git-Push. Alles klar.
Jetzt mal...
Ich probiere mal kurz was.
Könnte ich den Kram in Bash irgendwie
machen? Also ich meine,
das ist jetzt zwar hier für Business Enterprise,
aber mal drauf
geschissen. Das hier ist ja
eigentlich erstmal der Kern des Ganzen.
Der Rest ist easy.
Also lasst doch mal kurz gucken, ob wir da irgendwie
zumindest, vielleicht nicht Fertiges, aber
irgendeinen Lösungsansatz in Bash hinkriegen würden.
Also.
Als erstes ist es einfach...
Also die ID rauszukriegen ist einfach.
Das sparen wir uns.
Die ID kriegt man im Endeffekt
raus mit...
So. So würden
wir... Moment.
Fuck. So. So würden wir
die ID rauskriegen in Bash.
Okay. Das ist schon mal... Das ist die ID.
Aber um die ID...
Um die ID...
Mach ich mir jetzt
gar nicht so sehr die Gedanken.
Wie würde ich denn jetzt
beispielsweise die
Nummern richtig zählen?
Das ist halt echt sowas, wo eine anständige
Programmiersprache nicht verkehrt wäre.
Also.
Die Nummern könnten wir uns irgendwie rausholen.
E grepp.
Grepp kann keine Digits.
Aber grepp
grepp-p kann Digits.
So. Wir probieren mal das gleiche
wie in .net. Blue.
Green.
Ist das gerade ein Hakenkreuz oder so?
Was zum Teufel war das
gerade für ein Zeichen, man?
Monkatorsel, Alter.
Was für ein Sonderzeichen habe ich da
gerade aus Versehen eingefügt.
Habt ihr das gesehen?
Was war das gerade?
Hier. Ne. Ne. Okay.
Hoh. Nochmal Glück gehabt.
Nochmal Glück gehabt, Alter.
Also wenn man Alt-G-R-A
drückt, kommt dieses
Zeichen. Das sah ein bisschen aus wie ein
Hakenkreuz aus dem Augenwinkel, ey.
Monkatorsel, Mann.
Close.
So.
So kriege ich die ganzen Dinger raus.
Hier.
Jetzt ist bloß die Frage,
wie würde ich jetzt im Bash
Weil ich meine, das mit grepp
das mit grepp irgendwie
matchen ist ja das eine.
Aber
das jetzt extrahieren
ich glaube, da habe ich gerade kein
Brain dafür
das in Bash zu machen.
Weil das Ding ist
Wobei. Wobei. Wobei.
Wobei.
Moment. Moment.
Moment. Moment. Grepp kann
keine Ragex-Groups. Das ist ja das Ding.
Moment. Moment. Moment. Wartet mal, Leute.
Ich habe eine Idee.
Split.
Split. Moment.
Bash. Split. Line.
IFS.
Oh, nee. Please.
Mit Cut auf die Idee bin ich auch schon gekommen.
Nee, Leute.
Ja, wie gesagt, das mit IFS geht,
das ist mir klar. Aber das ist mir...
Da habe ich jetzt echt keinen Bock drauf,
das in Bash zu machen.
Das ist mir zu advanced.
Wir haben jetzt die Sharplösung.
Und ich merke auch, dass
mein Hirn gerade nicht mehr richtig funktioniert.
Wir gucken noch mal kurz in Tag 3 rein.
Und ich gucke mal, ob ich Tag 3
auf Anhieb verstehe.
Dann probieren wir vielleicht Tag 3 aus.
Ansonsten lasse ich es sein
und mache nachher noch ein bisschen Kreiselgrind.
Bash wäre noch frei.
Wirklich?
Es hat noch keiner in Bash gemacht?
Nice.
Dann wird es Zeit.
Okay, was wollen die? Blablabla.
Blablabla.
Okay, what?
Tag 3 ist Pain.
Wenn ich sowas schon sehe...
Also, was?
Blablabla.
Es erklärt, dass die Maschine
von der Maschine vermisst ist.
Aber niemand kann herausfinden, welches.
Wenn man alle Teilnummern
hinzufügen kann...
Also das hier?
Es sollte einfach sein,
an welchem Teil die Maschine vermisst ist.
...
Es besteht aus einer visuellen
Repräsentation der Maschine.
Es gibt viele Nummern und Symbolen,
die man nicht wirklich versteht.
Also...
Was ist das?
Es flexibilityiert die Maschine.
Das heißt du wirst Watchtower sein.
Was ist da irgendwie da?
Was ist da?
E revierkensauce-
Es ist neu.
Er bekommt 4-
ja noch gedacht wenn es wenn es davor davor okay ich mein von von der idee her
von stars du musst du musst zählen wie lange die zeile ist und dann musst du
gucken ob in der zeile unten drunter irgendwas stehe auf fakir punkte kauten
nicht als symbol also bedeutet im endeffekt die drei ist okay die fünf ist
okay die sieben ist okay ja sowas in der richtung also hier ist auch wieder
die sieben okay hier ist die vier okay die sechs okay die fünf die neuen also
diagonal und die sieben hier oben auch die gesamte die mag das ist nicht nur
die nummer das ist die gesamte zahl auch noch das ist richtig eklig
da habe ich keinen nerv drauf wird das mache ich einfach auf stream und tun
nächsten stream so als wüsste ich es ist reinen chat gpt das ist ja witzlos in
diskretik to numbers and not partners because ja das habe ich das habe ich
schon gecheckt das habe ich gecheckt muss man kurz gucken wo ich meinen chat
gpt passwort habe auch fakt habe ich hier gar nicht drin
mein passwort safe warum nicht jetzt habe ich ein problem
habe ich das bei mir im handy vielleicht stehen irgendwo wo ich das doch haben
ja ich habe keine ahnung wo ich meinen chat gpt passwort habe war da schon eine
weile nicht mehr drin eingeloggt ich muss mal passwort recovery machen
vielleicht vielleicht finde ich dann raus wartet mal passwort passwort recovery
change passwort verorten
requested
naja habe ich requested schön enter new password
alles klar noch mal schauen ob ich mich jetzt einloggen kann
jetzt kann ich mir einloggen sehr gut exzellent konnte man okay chat dann
müsst ihr mal kurz dann müsst ihr mal kurz ausgeblendet werden und dann kann
ich mich einloggen openai chat loggen loggen loggen loggen loggen loggen loggen
okay ich bin eingeloggt jetzt jetzt bin ich mal gespannt ob chat gpt das checkt
jetzt jetzt bin ich bin ich wirklich mal gespannt
okay ich mache euch wieder an ihr seht jetzt gleich wieder was ich habe auch
kein premium hier oder sonst was im account also dann test dann test dann
checken wir es doch mal okay ich glaube das wird nichts ich glaube hier kann uns
chat gpt nicht helfen
exploring
ich gehe aber davon aus wenn man das chat gpt ordentlich fragen würde dann dann
wird es wahrscheinlich das ganze checken wir können mal was ausprobieren wir lassen
mal die zweite hälfte weg okay
wir lassen mal die zweite hälfte weg ups wir gehen nur mal das erste da und jetzt각
was ist number of the nåmenbroлавavian tho sengler der partnerpartner us jeel internacional
numbers in the end wir geben wir geben ihm das hier und dann fragen wir am ende einfach nur
was zusammen weil hier steht ja schon die antwort drin ich will jetzt dass er 4361 sagt aber wie
gesagt ich glaube dass ich glaube das checkt da nicht wir können sagen diagonal numbers count
es will nicht wirklich okay ich glaube es macht ich glaube das macht keinen sinn korrekt als war
es ja das problem ist ach so war ich habe eine idee dollar sein diagonal numbers next to the
dollar sein
a 3 5 5 9 8 nicht wirklich okay das wusste ich da ist chat geht da müssen wir doch chat da
müssen wir doch das nächste mal selbst selbst dran so wie es aussieht das kriege ich heute
nicht gebacken jetzt baut mir wobei muss man sich für bad einloggen google ich bin doch
hier noch mit meinem fake account eingeloggt oder hier hier pro max 152 ja alles klar
fänger count es baut trai bacht jetzt mor gedacht regel konnten die ok bach not go ok dann
fragen wir nicht ja auch wir machen das hier nicht example kucken was dort erzählt ich bin
fähig online erstellt hat tier wir haben die letzte aufgabe schon ohne entre gemacht wollte
einfach noch gucken ok bat steigt komplett aus bthen gar keinen l targeted con mit make
ات
der bekannten fazit
Hi guys
aktuell sagen wir mit deinem mittlerweile'M一点2020
hammer
immer noch nicht daqui zu kommen wir haben also einen neuen sch frightening for the next
last takeaways today we are에서는 in azera
we surrounding the real world coffee friendly movie so den flaps trinket euch auf und likelihood
amok land division wir Uz restrictions umfulstert dazu wir schётся in der ad zu earlier today we're doing things to
Gar keinen Bock drauf.
Wir lassen mal das Gelaber weg.
Äh, nein.
Oh, jetzt kommt Python-Stells an den Start hier.
Diagonal Numbers.
Okay, Bart hat auch keinen Bock.
Dann werden wir das das nächste Mal wohl doch selbst machen müssen, ne?
Na, unabhängig davon, ich hätte es so und so selbst gemacht.
Habe ich jetzt eigentlich gepusht?
Ja.
C++ war schon dran.
Ne, ich habe mir überlegt, ob ich Tag 2 nicht noch in Bash mache.
Aber da reicht meine Gehirnkapazität heute echt nicht mehr aus für.
Und Tag 3 sieht schon nach Ultra-Abfuck aus.
Wenn ich es mir schon ansehe überhaupt, ja.
Da habe ich heute echt keinen F drauf mehr.
Ich bin heute eh ein bisschen kaputt noch von den letzten Tagen.
Das kriege ich heute nicht hin.
Da würde ich bestimmt jetzt noch mal eineinhalb Stunden für brauchen oder so.
Wenn überhaupt.
Bis ich das heute hinkriege.
Da warte ich lieber drauf, bis mein Hirn sich ein bisschen beruhigt hat wieder.
Der Chat hat Zeit.
Ja, das kann sein, dass der Chat Zeit hat.
Zeit habe ich auch, aber ich habe kein Gehirn mehr heute.
Eigentlich müsste ich jetzt eine Runde Kreisel-Crime starten.
Ja, hier ist...
Brain is Matschke.
Die letzten paar Tage waren zu viel.
Also für alle, die es nicht mitgekriegt haben, meine Katze ist ja gestern gestorben.
Und das war richtig sätge.
Extremely sätge.
Deswegen hatte ich da jetzt nicht so...
Chat, ihr könnt mir mal einen Gefallen tun.
Können wir einmal im Chat für alle Leute, die da sind.
Einmal im Chat.
Ihr wisst, ich bin nicht großartig gläubig.
Darum geht es nicht.
Einmal eine Runde alle im Chat.
Pregge für Chico.
Äh, Chico schreibt man übrigens so.
Chico.
Falls irgendjemand Chico dabei schreiben will.
Eine Runde Pregge, Pregge für Chico, okay?
Excellent, Chat.
Das ist jetzt doch schon gleich viel besser alles.
Community-Ge.
Ja.
Zugeschlagen.
Leute am Start, die noch nie was im Chat geschrieben haben jetzt, ne, aber Pregge Chico, schön, dass ihr alle mitgemacht habt.
Alles klar.
Leute, wir machen heute nicht weiter.
Mir reicht's für heute.
Ich habe das am Anfang.
Streams schon vermutet, dass mein Hirn heute nicht ausreicht, um zwei Aufgaben zu machen.
Aber morgen weiter.
Vielleicht gibt's jetzt.
Gleich noch in einer Stunde oder so.
Bisschen weiter.
Kreisel-Grind.
Weil ich muss ja meine Charts weiterleveln.
Guck mal kurz in Discord.
Vielleicht fang ich auch gleich an.
Nein, nein.
Nicht.
Wow.
Discord.
Lass mal kurz checken.
Äh, hier ist nix.
Hier ist auch nix.
Dann anscheinend nicht.
Ja.
Also ich muss, ich muss meine Hexe ordentlich ausrüsten noch.
Mein Skaldo ordentlich ausrüsten in Dark.
Und wahrscheinlich noch ein Charmy leveln.
Also wir haben.
Genug Kreisel-Grind-Material.
noch aber nachher ich komme nachher noch mal irgendwie eine stunde oder sommer gucken und
dann old school mmo kreisel client wenn ich übrigens da ist das so viele am start sind da
gucken immer so 60 70 leute zu was nicht selbstverständlich ist für irgendwie dann
20 jahre als gamer also bis nachher leute kreisel klein startet dann für progress programmiert
stellt habe ich heute nicht mehr genug gehirn kapazität wir hören uns nachher
und wenn ihr da nicht dabei seid dann morgen bis dann macht's gut